Am I it does here we go mean I can go or
okay you're listening to the dollop on
the all things comedy Network this is a
bilingual American history podcast where
each week I Dave Anthony miracle worker
man who hates Miracle Whip these are
miracle themed and a third I can't think
of another miracle thing short on reads
a story miracle American used to live on
the Miracle Mile reads a story from
American history to his friend whoa
Gareth Reynolds who has no idea what the
topic is about and nemesis and that was
brutal not we're not never sigh again
for the last time I pick who my nemesis
is I do this we talk your one
opportunity it's not how it works
it just doesn't we'll see cuz life's
long and chicken get really weird what
is that
I mean it's a horrible thing to say to
someone that is absolutely a friend of
yours let's just keep going I mean this
part of the show is not it's just what
it's not a good part it's a part where
we talk about honesty and we share our
feelings I just helped you name your
third thing in your dumb bio so I think
wow you really explained that well I'm
drill we're all we're so ready to start
nobody cares and this is not gonna come
to tickle yeah now hit him with the
puppy you both resent sick arguments
we tell people that's the comment about
action court
no unless he died my friend
at some point I'm gonna actually
remember to bring in the new theme but
it said we're coming up on where we are
400 we are this is 400 prabha new fuse
yeah okay great
good idea we don't have a lot of time on
that so let's just say our dates we're
gonna be in Wisconsin will be in Madison
on October 18th we'll be in Milwaukee on
October 20th and then in November we are
off to Europe now we'll be in Stockholm
Oslo Amsterdam Cardiff Birmingham
Manchester sold-out glad sold-out London
we added a second show in London on the
22nd they're still tickets available for
that one and then we're in Dublin and
they're still tickets available for
Dublin so not someone was like hey I'm
sorry I didn't buy tickets in time for
Dublin and I look I'm like no there's
still take it seems like I just assumed
you were sold out that's a good way
that's that's the perfect air you want
to have just have people think you're
sold out so you don't sell out it's just
that's a great fan base it's perfect
it's exactly what you want just to get
to that level
it's the minimal amount of effort I can
you experience that right where your
shows are empty because everyone things
are so popular we should say who's here
oh yeah joining us we've never had an
in-studio guest
except your mom which not really guest
as much as just like a family member
sure that make sense I'd rather keep
talking our guest our first ever
celebrity guest house that celebrity
Pam's not so well I mean I think our
guest this bigger than panel patton
oswalt joins us for a number 400 hello
everyone hi what's my which cameras mind
where's my goddamn eye line oh yeah we
might sound one yeah yeah we're also my
intro unbelievable obviously I decided
to make you seem charming originally so
for this episode
I lied to Patton I told them it was
gonna be that Henry Kissinger to get in
here oh you thought that would get me
yeah
yeah yeah it did for Hitchens leave any
meat on those bones
he's got she loved Genesis so it's not
about Kissinger I wasn't lied to it also
I'm still here hey errand you want to
put up the image Wow
number 400 yeah is our friend Ronald
Reagan that's right our WR do it hell
yeah
February 6 1911 whoo year of our Lord
Jesus Christ Ronald Wilson Reagan was
born at home well yeah nice his horn is
save that sorry he's not quite there no
sorry
his parents were Jack and Nell and he
had an older brother Neal young Ronald
was no I had a Dutch boy haircut so he
was known as Dutch sure for a long time
he was called Dutch I'm not gonna call
him Dutch
Jack and now acted in local shows and
Jack really liked to drink great okay
and his drink he became worse and worse
and worse over the years family moved a
lot five times in ten years when he was
young Jack would sell shoes and so he'd
go to a different town he'd get fired
for drinking and they move on to the
next town just a good old-fashioned life
it wasn't perfect it could be a guy who
sells shoes and show up in a new town a
bit I got I know shoes and I don't drink
let's give him a house anyway he's got
two kids and a wife get my house so they
finally settled for good and Dixon
Illinois Jack was very very liberal he
was very vocal about it he talked about
reapportioning wealth he was very
against the Ku Klux Klan and he
instilled a respect for FDR in young
Ronald
so Ronald Grubb idolizing FDR grew up
there as you can see yeah a liberal
connection seems clear it's yeah he was
athletic he played basketball baseball
and he ran track
he went to Eureka College and joined the
Tau Kappa Epsilon fraternity Caitlyn
yeah it's one of the best e-tanks yeah
you Absalon and man yeah yeah
he at some point the fraternity demanded
the college president's resignation
after he decided to cut some programs
okay so Ronald's fraternity is behind
this big movement they get everyone to
go on strike right there's like what
strike what service are you removing
their employees the students go on
strike they go on strike okay we are we
are halting our intellects and not
gaining any more knowledge right now
yeah knowledge strike and freshman
Ronald Reagan gives the speech of
demands okay because he's a big liberal
uh-huh and they win and the president is
forced out whoa Ronald Reagan learns the
power of strike and that was the basis
of the movie Animal House dbl check that
out I might be wrong go ahead after
college Ronald wanted to work in radio
but he got a job at the start Courier
newspaper and his job was to announce
baseball scores okay that's pretty sure
what he would do is every so the
baseball scores are coming after the
paper was printed right so what he would
do is he was hired to walk out on the
second-floor balcony with a megaphone
and he would announce baseball scores to
fans sorry
a sport crier so he said yeah he's a
human glockenspiel like oh it's three
o'clock Reagan's coming out hello
citizen it's the male ticker he would
sit in the street he would walk out and
go I guess the the Cardinals scored it's
three to two
great job Wow talk about a job where you
could drink like your father so he was a
podcaster yes started a podcast yeah
that's right yeah
so that kicked off his sports
broadcasting career from there he moved
into radio and he worked his way all the
way up to announcing for the Cubs okay
now he would he wouldn't go to games he
would announce they would go out and it
would and they would someone would send
him what was happening through Morse
code and then he would make it up on the
fly he would make what upon them he
would get like a Morse code thing and be
like someone stole third like they had
Morse code for everything that was
happening on the field will he make it
seem like he was watching it as it
happened yes and he was he would play a
record that had applause and he hit it
with his becoming hey like genuinely
kind of sad man so we're down the street
is a lot of people didn't show up to the
games because I thought they were sold
out so he so he did that for a while he
became huge he has millions of listeners
listening to his Cubs game where he's
fake calling writer he announces for
four years and then he talks him into
sending he talks miss the the owners
into setting him out with the cups of
spring training okay because he has his
eyes on Hollywood it was a spring
training in California
the Cubs used to train on Catalina
Island they wait the Chicago Cubs and
also knowing how difficult transport was
back yeah yeah let's get them moving
across cooking and then off the
continent to an island what's the
hardest place we can catch it welcome to
baseball Island you play for your lies
boys if you get cut you got to swim off
Lord just seems insanely efficient yeah
right so he start last three on the
journey of spring training yeah we lost
that picture in a swell it's all right
big tidal surge boys the bullpens
drowned boys next year we're getting a
boat to get in the air
that'll be good that's a good investment
so he starts networking and soon he gets
a screen test and Warner's offers him a
seven-year contract okay so they changed
his name from Dutch to Ray uh Dutch
Reagan the Ronald Reagan
so what hang on so he was full-time
Dutch reg he was Dutch Reagan and this
is the first time he became Ronald
Reagan you know welcome to the Dutch
trade the Dutch Reagan Radio Hour just
being a crowd full of people who drop
the needle Bob listen to them today they
sound just like last week his parents
move close so Ronald couldn't help take
care of them it's nice dad still drunk
that's still drinking these guys need
shoes do your friends need shoes Ron dad
get the car his parents lived in West
Hollywood all right oh that's true yeah
Ronald was in eight movies in 1938 all B
movies and then he started dating Jane
Wyman while she was married to her
second husband the Screen Actors Guild
sag play a record of her having orgasm
had sex that's right you like that don't
you she would send him telegrams as to
what she was doing sex more sex the
Screen Actors Guild sag had just started
ronald called sag quote a damned noble
organization nice okay he became very
involved and Ronald loved to talk about
politics
some actors found him annoying when they
worked with him one actor said they
would all tried to avoid sitting with
him at lunch oh my god to avoid quote
professor Reagan's discourses Oh God and
if professor Reagan over there you know
where we got bean sprouts it
really good lord but turns out Ronald
had gotten a subscription to Reader's
Digest and he would read every episode
front to back and regurgitate it to
anyone who would listen well that's the
problem with him getting these crier
gigs he's just like if I just talk to
people they're in you know that reminds
me of how humor can be found in uniform
one time as the table vacates well like
we know what you're doing Ronny I just
wanted to sit alone yeah just imagine oh
yeah do you know how tables were made up
a god sake
a man found a piece of wood and then he
found four others hold on I'm just
getting going you won't believe what
happens next there's a table I can't
believe Reader's Digest made this into a
10th page story but here we go what I
ride so Jane was pressuring Ronald into
marrying and he did not want to marry
he's dragging his feet so she threatened
to kill herself if she did he didn't Wow
how God which is not powerful not a red
flag no no yeah usually you do it I mean
obviously do it what what she really
wants you don't date that girl you marry
her I didn't think you were serious
until you did yeah say these feelings
are for real so she did she in January
1940 she Oded on pills and was
hospitalized Jesus Christ and the next
day they were engaged ladies that's how
you do it
Oh survivors ve gained wine Wow
I didn't believe you it is very hard at
that point it's hard to say no you
really boxed in you really are well yeah
I mean she's in a hospital bed you're
like you for sure yeah we should totally
yes absolutely the she lets talk to some
doctors and let some of some brain
people but yeah so uh he didn't want to
have a baby she did so they had a baby
yeah you don't push back anymore in this
marriage this is now is not its unleash
packable
you know anything I'd like you to sleep
in the tub all right call me why just
this is part and parcel with him just
regurgitating what he's told to do read
these sports scores marry this crazy
woman hat she's monster baby give her a
bit all right I so they had baby Maureen
Ronald got his big break in 1940 in
Knute Rockne All American Jack died and
and they supported Ronald's mom so
Ronald gotta leave the shoes to the
reading of the will the shoes it's gonna
be a while guys he had a lot of them he
was drunk he was burying some of them we
don't know what he was doing at a yard
there's a bunch of shoe Maps here so
let's get Imelda Marcos yeah yeah
so Ronald the wars on Ronald is a
pacifist what a vocal pacifists but he
gets called up he gets to deferments
Warner's health amount elder marijuana
but after - they're like he got to go so
in 1942 he's assigned to go into the
army okay and he is sent to first motion
picture unit in Hollywood what what
actually Culver City okay you're serving
under Colonel Carla do you even need to
take a bus anywhere gonna drive on the
base right up front to action you slimy
scumbag you call that acting I want five
exits and I want a mouth now you choke
yourself so what they did was they made
ricoeur been filled
he was in some he narrated some he was
on recruiting posters and he went around
the country selling bombs so he's like a
Salesman for the world exactly yeah
which I don't think it was hard to get
people to join but whatever people
people were fired up as a pacifist this
is weird a bit of a shift yeah but kind
of perfect form he doesn't have to go
fight right logically yes that actually
he's not the shift is too personal
pacifism yeah I don't think you really
as we get through this story you'll
you'll really she doesn't care about
other people all that much what Ronnie
so he never leaves the US during the war
but because he's so out there he's
considered a war hero right he's he's
the PR guys Wow
the face of the face fantastic
way to go Ron in March 1945 they adopted
a baby Michael Edward and in December
1945 Ronald was discharged okay now so
that's about 20 years all right clean
out your trailer to new soldier turning
your food put the commissary coffee down
you have been discharged is army coffee
the regular ones actually next to it so
he now he's it's things have changed he
is sort of his type as completely
outdated in Hollywood they're suddenly
looking for nuanced interesting actors
and he's really one-dimensional and
bland but he's like the old-school on
time and sober right so to unions IATSE
and CSU were fighting for control of
crews in Hollywood okay and I Otzi
called csa communists all right and so
ronald became a sag vice-president and
CSU want to go on strike but Ronald
hated communists okay so he got sag to
align with iaat see and reject the call
for a strike okay he said the strike
quote was a plot to get economic control
of the picture business and that the
Communists were subverting Hollywood to
spur revolution here it is here's a nice
little bend is her boy nice little bend
happening finally he's complete a
scientist elongated
yeah so he talked endlessly as we said
at a party he started blathering and
Jane whispered to a friend quote I'm so
bored with him I'll either kill him or
kill myself that's by the way not an
idle threat
yeah no no when she whispers that you
like change we don't by the way back
then one of the ways you'd be branded a
communist this is true is if you hated
Nazism too early I'm not kidding early
on in the early 30s it was communism or
or Nazism and I hated Nazis and totally
like well dear obviously a comment in
other words yet you have you hating
Nazism at the right time yeah literally
would get you tagged a communist because
it first fascism wasn't bad right all
the stat is bad by America right it's
still easily that's actually very true
exactly
so another night out they were with a
couple and Jane said quote hey diary of
the mouth shut up maybe we can get in a
word in edgewise Wow alright so she's
fully she's comes out of the cocoon and
flying out hey diary I'm out like a
jerky boy now that's like a like a
lockhorns comic yeah I mean honestly hey
diarrhea mouth hey you traveled around
with a symbol a sizzle chest
Jane told June Allyson quote don't ask
Ronnie what time it is because he will
tell you how a watch is made so there I
mean that's just a great Barrett yeah so
Ronald still considers himself a New
Deal Democrat he believes in government
he he thinks that government shouldn't
own public utilities and not private
companies he's big into public housing
like he's on board with the whole
[ __ ] deal and he thought he had a
duty at the same time to root out
communists right so McCarthyism comes
along and Hollywood rats are naming
names that's right and the FBI recruited
Ronald Reagan as a snitch Jesus Christ
Ronnie I miss Dutch yeah so he would
baseball scores I'd okay yeah share
private SAG files with the FBI
holy [ __ ] Wow yeah what a douche yeah
and named suspected communists wow those
were usually actors who opposed his sag
leadership Wow so he was I'm amazed he
didn't use it like against actors that
were getting roles that he that would
have been a nice move like he did it to
help his own career to get all the
claims Montgomery Clift's not available
anymore guess I'll have to step in and I
do more nuanced stuff it's Kohli another
guy who looked just like you Ron that's
right I don't know what the problem is
I'm the only good one left it seems so
Raul became president of sag in March
1947 Jane was pregnant with their third
child it's good to keep having children
of this yeah it sounds lovely
I think it's only shot him up right hey
hey diarrhea mouth throw a baby in me
okay all right I guess I can sling one
but do you want to hear about no [ __ ] me
well you know the gas turbines after
sing history put the show put the pillow
on your mom well it's gonna be a while
but you hear about the baseball scores
Cardinals are dipping rock you know bees
can't see the color red is it so Ronald
shooting a movie she move with a Shirley
Temple it's like her first like I'm an
adult movie oh wow and he decides to do
his own stunts
okay Shirley Temple exactly it's just
jumping into a lake well the first John
wick movie was a remake of the Shirley
Temple one I was originally a Shirley
Temple John wick little cutie grown up
all growed up so he jumps in this cold
lake over and over and over and over
again and a couple days later later he
is hospitalized with pneumonia Oh God
and it's a bad kind it's like some weird
viral one and they don't know if he's
gonna live or die yes like so Jane goes
into premature labor has the baby baby
dies so he gets out he survives sorry
yeah stuff the ripple effect of that
lake death really yeah really change
some things I think really what of that
lake would be a National Monument we got
it I could do one more now we're good
that directors call shame history in
October Ron testified in front of the
HUAC as a friendly witness right
communists hearings he didn't name
anyone but when he came home Jane
demanded a divorce she got custody of
the children and after the divorce
Ronald ran into Errol Flynn hmm Flint
told him quote be happy old sport think
of the parties think of the girls do
what I do
well yeah have sex with
thirteen-year-old yeah that's not a
don't follow that example it was good
news right yeah
have you ever drink a quart of gin and
then take your dick out of the
playground it's like old Errol Flynn
have you ever heard her Errol Flynn
episode it's crazy I know that I mean
I've read his autobiography it's
horrifying
it's he say he was a horrifying him and
maybe one of the worst humans ever
totally was oh wow so this is 15 years
after arils rape trials her ronald takes
his advice obviously obviously and
begins womanizing Ronald had read that
World War 1 vets were forgiven their
taxes for the years they served right so
when they serve they came back and like
you don't pay taxes yes yours thank you
for your service attacks per year so he
knew that when he went into the service
so he just didn't pay his taxes that
year thinking that the same thing would
happen to World War two vets okay huh
that didn't happen oh the government did
not forgive their taxes okay
Ronald was livid he was in Hollywood
like I underst
I mean he is literally acting like he's
a soldier now yeah not only hard I was
born to play not only was he in
Hollywood but his salary like his normal
salary was like in our in our money be
like $45,000 a year and then when he
went into the army it was it was like
you know a thousand bucks a month like
he didn't have to pay that much in taxes
right but he was just mad by the concept
of it like he's like he's like one of
those dads is forced to pay alimony is
mad yeah right men's rights listen I
served those key lights were hot all
right some of those close up for brutal
we lost two grips at lunch that ravioli
is old still haunted
so his acting career is now floundering
as we said any movies and he's getting
batteries there's no audiences coming
out um also I think post-divorce James
skyrocketed yeah she's taking her career
leg got started going really well that's
good yeah yeah so Jack Warner also casts
Errol Flynn in a movie that Ronald had
brought to the studio he brings the
script of the studio and he's like can I
make this and he's like yeah just do
these other movies first Anna
casting Errol Flynn in the movie that
rock brought - he's not happy about that
right No
then in June 1949 ronald broke his leg
in six places in a charity baseball game
it's a charity I'm gonna clean him yeah
I tried to slide into tour Johnson
snapped his beam well I'm out yeah Ethel
Merman like blind arrived him she's the
catcher if she spiked him so he spent
six weeks in the hospital I'd like
interaction or whatever you know Jesus
and then he reflects on his life he's 38
he's divorced he's got a fading movie
career
so things he's realizing things aren't
great now Nancy Davis had been kicking
around Hollywood for a while sure she
was raised by her actress mother and
doctor stepfather who was not tolerant
of anyone he believed to be
intellectually inferior sure that
included blacks Catholics and Jews
hmm interesting Nancy adored him she
accepted his belief that quote men were
to be the leaders and women to follow
she studied drama at college and drama
white drama right quite manly drama only
white manly drama she gets out to become
an actress and now Spencer Tracy had
been nursed through his alcoholic binges
by Nancy stepfather uh-huh okay so by
the way when he would finish a movie he
would check into this true he would she
would stay sober during the shooting he
would check into a hotel room with a
steamer case full of liquor he would sit
naked in the bathtub I just drink puke
and [ __ ] all over himself
stand up wash it all down the drain sit
down and just keep
going for like two weeks I thought he
would do in between shoot I'm not
kidding it was just what are you doing
for hiatus Spence I'm doing the old [ __ ]
flume again I just wrapped on Captains
Courageous and it's time to drink of
Adam Scott off to my waist tub and yet
that is someone's porn yeah if someone
wants that yeah yeah damn and I want to
get him one of those dispenser Tracy
please tell me somebody film that so hit
her stepfather nursed him through these
benches or whatever he had to deal with
is the end of those no I mean what did
you just stand in the bathroom like all
right Spencer nice [ __ ] I assumed that
he would take him out of it so he could
get to him I'm sure he would at the end
of the titute he was on right he would
then do a week of drying them out get
him cuz he was like we need him in a
week yeah okay all right pick him up out
of his vomit tub get the hose Hey
hose off Spencer Tracy we got this desk
set script just gonna be really good or
government Oscar somebody host them up
hands are tied meat cleaver I got a meat
hook this is really caked on the back
like paint it's like from Scarface
Exhibit D Mahmoud Spencer we got a
shooting here at the Wynn so he because
in the connection promises to get Nancy
a screen test
okay at the same time he gives her a
number to Clark Gable and they dated for
a few months hey thanks Ron the studio
casting director so he gets like a big
director to shoot it and a big actor and
gives it to the studio casting director
who watches Nancy's screen test and
quote told the studio she had no talent
okay-dokey
but Tracy still got the studio to sign
her anyway Wow yeah
Nancy dated a few men according to Kitty
Kelly Nancy quote was around in
Hollywood for performing oral sex
what Wow best he was in Hollywood this
city Kelly book it was pretty brutal
that was uh and I and I looked and I
looked into it I'd like to see if it was
really not and and everyone's like yeah
it's salacious but there's a lot of
there's real it's real okay so at some
point she decided she wanted Ronald okay
and she set her sights on him and he
finally asked her out
she loved his non-stop chatter okay this
is new to me tell me more about how a
lock system works not easy it's lengthy
and not easy not entertaining the Head
Start do you know about rope so she
realized that astrology was the key to
his heart oh I thought that was a thing
that didn't happen till the white the
far back is the 40 she was Wow so she
would go to monthly meetings with Ronald
at Carol writers mansion writer was big
[ __ ] in Hollywood he was a Philadelphia
lawyer who became an astrologer and now
advised big names like Cary Grant
Princess Grace and Ronald Reagan Wow
okay okay so astrology is like this big
thing yeah in public Nancy always tried
to be by Ronald side and she would spend
as much time as she could with his kids
playing singing dancing having a good
time okay they dated for three years and
all the while Ronald saw their women wow
think he was in love with an actress
named Christine Larson who he proposed
to in 1951 but she turned him down
okay so they kept their relationship
secret
me and Nancy he and no Nancy's out he
and Christine knows about Christine oh
my god so photos would appear in
magazines of Ronald
with many women may 1950s silver-screen
quote never thought we'd come right out
and call Ronnie Reagan a wolf but let's
face it suddenly every glamour gal
considers him a super sexy escort for
the evening it's too much too much look
at the wolf taking the meat back to the
lair
yum-yum-yum a lifter rod Reagan at it
again
[Laughter]
they were also women he did not take out
in public who he was seeing like
Jacqueline Park quote Ronnie never took
me out in public never gave me a present
he swore me to secrecy about our
relationship and said I couldn't tell
anybody at the studio about us sounds
like a pretty healthy relationship when
I got pregnant I found out that our
relationship didn't really mean anything
to him at all
he said you're what well it's not from
me not mine no sir it's not mine he was
awful he said I know how you Hollywood
starlets play around with everybody and
then you try to blame good people like
me but you can't get away with it
there's no proof that you've been ever
been with me you just gonna have to work
this one out for yourself I don't want
to be involved and then he hung up on me
I didn't know what to do he was so
powerful and I was just a nobody so I
called my friend and he arranged for me
to have an abortion is win one for the
Gipper yep then then Nancy right after
that found out she was pregnant okay
let's see how Ronnie Hannah yes yeah
from the mouth well first first he went
right to she know it if she'd only just
said we immediately told Christine first
and say no trapped what yeah creep a few
days later Ronald hit on Celine Walters
at a club
she was 19 he was 41 she gave her number
and address hoping he'd help her career
okay but Ronald showed up at 3:00 a.m.
that night quote he forced me on the
couch and I kept trying to keep a
conversation going saying stupid things
like Oh tell me about your latest movie
and Oh we'll talk about that another
time you're so beautiful let's get to
know each other he was so big I couldn't
fight him off it was the most pitch
battle I've ever had and suddenly in a
matter of seconds I lost I was so
shocked and angry because he had spoiled
everything I told him to but he said oh
I just couldn't help myself
don't worry about a thing I'm gonna call
you and we'll go hang out and then we'll
talk some more about your career a week
later she's read that her rapist was
marrying Nancy Davis oh [ __ ] this is I
mean I know this guy's a shitheel yeah I
did not recognize that he was a rapist
yeah well I mean which it's that
gigantic cosmic historical [ __ ] [ __ ]
but yeah but then you're like oh yeah
even in the little tiny personal moments
he was also the origin story as oh yeah
thing he could be shitty about he was
shitty about yeah in the macro and ugh I
mean the list of presidents who have
rapes i won in it's just it's it's crazy
but yeah like it's almost now lady you
got thing you right of passage but again
you can keep in mind that up until
recently men forcing themselves on women
was a scene as a charming thing
sometimes like you watch the [ __ ]
James Bond movies or yeah you know
they're just forcing themselves like
well what a man yeah I know yeah it's
really really gnarly I mean what three
of our last six presidents yeah yeah I
mean yeah that we know of that we know
that way yeah that's probably more I
think we could protect Jimmy Carter off
the list
probably dodged the bat we're probably
pretty he's been he's been Rick yeah
he's the one who's saying to someone
like no means no just I can I just
trying to build you a house yeah so
Nancy was two and half months pregnant
when they married she refused to have
anything to do with his kids after they
got married so right she's playing with
him she gets married done Wow and then
who was the kid they had together that
was Patricia okay so his career was
drying up and Nancy had no career they
had a lot of overhead they had a home a
ranch supporting his mom child support
and the IRS state debt uh-huh so for
money he became a nightclub act in Vegas
what what quite a wrinkle David I took
it out because there was nine of her but
it was just like song and dance [ __ ] it
was what you think I'd like to invite a
lady out of the audience so I could
assault her it's just reading sports
scores I'm doing the classics I'll do
the hits this is about communist my bad
he would read The Reader's Digest oh
sorry so these pages are stuck together
bear with me can you believe that's how
you make a table imagine two legs just
wasn't cutting it Nick's finger turns
page so that lasts three months yeah
Patricia Reagan's born he comes back
when Patricia was delivered the night of
the delivery Ronald was not at the
hospital he spent that time with
Christine Larson not soon after Ronald
went to Christine's and another man
answered the door in a bath towel Ronald
was furious he stormed off and that was
the end of his affair with Christine
Larson such betrayal yeah what do you
mean you're seeing someone else you're
mine you can't I can't find a loyal
mistress good lord what in the world I
need a monogamous mistress I can't for
this town it's just a bunch of it's a
den of sin now these mistresses are
cheating on these their married lovers
dirty dirty girl
disgusting do kind of love how much
[ __ ] was going on in Hollywood though
yeah it is nice yeah yeah it was
probably pretty cool you know
yeah everybody's got everybody pregnant
so TV starts taking off talent agency
MCA announced they were going to get
into TV production okay
so Ronald helped negotiate a waiver for
MCA to do both so SAG has to give them a
waiver because it's a super conflict of
interest right okay no other agency gets
away ever interesting
wait how that word Oh MCA represents
Ronald suddenly MCA got Ronald tons of
TV shows to be in at a higher rate than
he deserved so they gave him his old
rate from when he was a star as opposed
to like what he should get right now and
he's just working TV like God shows now
he's and TV shows and TV movies and okay
in 1953 Ronald was picked to host
General Electric Theater part of the job
was also to go to GE plants meet workers
and make speeches oh god oh no
the show is a huge hit and his G
handlers would give him right-wing
literature to educate him about the
problems with labor and things like that
Wow
and then at the same time Nancy's
stepfather who was a john birch ER wah
was chatting in his ear about how bad
here the left one is yeah a devil on
each show this is not mr. push back now
all right things to talk about I mean
talking points young his speech is one
over workers people related to him they
felt he understood and shared their
concerns soon other groups asked him to
speak and he would rant about communists
taking over unions and big government
GE theater had 25 million viewers a
we my god what's wrong became one of the
most recognized men in the country
Wow I always thought he was just in
shitty hate movies he was but no he was
a [ __ ] big stunt once TV came that
kind of saved him right yeah he was done
without TV exactly yeah he really hit a
wall
he had like he literally had I think one
good film role right Kings row
that's it and then everything everything
else was just now Bonzo don't you know
oh right I forgot about Bonzo yeah yeah
and then a terrible song and dance
movies like Dick Powell no Bob Dick
Powell also kind of pushed him to the
right by the way Bonzo from what I hear
in 1958 baby boy Ronald Prescott Reagan
arrived
Michael was 14 in acting out so Jane
sent him to live with his dad okay all
right now this is when seven-year-old
patty first met her half-brother Michael
oh wow
so I mean they're so separate Wow
I think she knew he existed but Nancy
wouldn't allow the kids around at all
well so far so he never she never right
so that is I mean as a parent imagine
yeah like your your your daughter
probably wish she had either another kid
brother sister so now imagine having one
and never never letting the meat yeah
like Dorothy the the monster you have to
be as a parent to do that like to me
that's like insane that the and the kid
grow as grows up really having it
hammered in their head it's my life is
getting lived first and then whatever is
left over you'll get but you're not the
main focus right right I didn't get into
it but I read that Michael wrote up
autobiography and at one point he wrote
in it that he thought that there that
the black maid was his mother until he
was like 8
so that guy's life was [ __ ] yeah and
so also Nancy is really a source of I
mean she is making him a worse yes yes
absolutely yeah so Nancy agreed to let
him come live with them if he went to
boarding school during the week and
stayed at the Malibu ranch with Ronald
on weekends
that's if he ever had to spend the night
at the Pacific Palisades home he had to
sleep on the couch that's nice olive
branch printing yeah for sure yeah
surely you're gonna grow up being a
generous person they're certainly gonna
be the kind of guy who really cares how
the waiters feeling it yeah yeah yeah in
November a 1959 Ronald he's back as
president of sag even though he's been
saying all this [ __ ] about unions right
so he is back as president and he
negotiates sag rituals for old movies
that are now being played on TV okay
right so no one no one knew that GE had
given him twenty twenty five percent
ownership of GE theater productions wow
so he's management and right we're
negotiating for actors right is he
getting a cut of the residuals of all
the movies or that's just it so that's
what he's negotiating for Wow so but
he's he's making tons of TV yeah right
yeah yeah since he's not gonna care
about the TV movies all that much so he
got Wow a good deal but there was a
one-time payout of 2.25 million for
movies that were made between 1948 and I
in 1959 and now that money was used to
start the health insurance and pension
plan so so so everyone else after at
1960 on if their movies are playing on
TV they would get residuals right so all
these old actors like Bob Hope and make
you they make you run your [ __ ] live
it because they got nothing about it
right right model doesn't care because
Ronald is making big TV money right
exactly and it seems like he did do
something in a way he did I mean for us
he did something good yes but he also he
also I would he have done knowing what
we know about this person would he have
done
I think he was not making to Nancy right
now certainly he would have without
question so at the next sag meeting a
member accused Ronald of bad faith
because he was both a union leader and
management okay finally the connection
was made
Wow with yarn on a cork board he's a
liar
he denied this but resigned the next
month you know wrote about this was
Wayne Federman I think it was an
Atlantic article really and in it Wayne
Federman is very adamant that he's not a
Republican I've talked to when bowl [ __ ]
so now most importantly this was around
the time that Ronald started calling
Nancy mom no I did sort of know that but
I think I've blocked it out like
personal drama my skin crawl Nami it's
the pet pence does that too right it
just mother mother
and Reagan is mommy mother is I think
March is horrifying my mother
so JFK was running against Nixon and the
JFK was running partially and creating
Medicare mm-hmm Ronald volunteer to make
a spoken-word record warning that
Medicare would lead to the government
takeover of quote every area of freedom
as we have known in this country there
it is
the start there that's the beginning
when we learned of the end the record
was sent out and played at meetings
across the country well can you think of
anything worse than a propagandist
Ronald Reagan our like flamengo flipping
that [ __ ] record over oh let's get to
the rest is a time when you would go to
a meeting and someone put on a record
oh yeah right yeah exactly or you go to
like some hosted
or they would go now we're gonna listen
to this record you can't he can't even
be bothered to and it's in Tallaght in
LA and to putting the record on that
he's a mile from us right now good
listen though
yeah but JFK won and Medicare became one
of the most popular government programs
of all time most popular team in ago
yeah
so still Ronald hit the lecture circuit
claiming JFK policies would lead to
quote social slavery yeah yeah Wow
but he has been proven right history has
shown us know yeah is that people hate
it so GE
cut Ronald loose after MCA was
investigated for a conflict of interest
by the judge environment and Ronald was
obviously caught up in that yeah and he
testified it was like oh I don't
remember I don't recall I don't know
which is gonna be a catchphrase for life
yeah also he had moved too far right for
even GE at this point Wow that's for the
most evil corporations and history's
like we gotta get rid of that honestly
you're freaking us out not good we are
genuinely irked by your behavior and we
are again the devil I mean we're making
napalm and your decree we are but we're
leaving you Ron I don't know how hard
that is that yeah it's not us it's you
and we say that openly and with with all
confidence when he was fired he said
quote Robert Kennedy is behind this
attack on me oh my god and he blamed JFK
for not being cast in films because his
agent was a JFK supporter I mean he had
stopped getting cast in films a decade
before that what do you
we're in motion this goes all the way to
the top John F Kennedy and Robert F
Kennedy don't like me acting hey rabbit
between you and me no more Reagan in
films that'll be my main platform now
our bonds are on the other hand it's got
legs and boy does he know how to use
them
Jimmy's got Bonzo an address in his room
I just love you stuff I've always been a
huge fan yeah whiskey do you drink
whiskey can you smoke is that true Oh
God so so the Reagan had a party planned
on the night JFK was assassinated a
guest called to see if it was still on
Nancy quote don't be silly
we'll expect to see you around 7:00 p.m.
wow I mean that's like 9/11 yes like
having a dinner party 9/11 well that
that's the equivalent of you know the
fake story about Muslims celebrating the
rise I'm celebrating a death right right
yeah that's them having a weird Enya was
probably some weird creepy blood ritual
yeah to the mansion and you know yeah
like on Levay was there a Pentagon and
sand yes right now drained the blood
from my penis should we drink you're
cutting a monkeys penis and you drinking
the blood out of it this is what do we
do
sorry Bonzo patty who was 11 at the time
said her parents showed in no motion
when JFK was murdered right so ronald
finally officially switched from
democrat to republican and soon he was
giving a half-hour speech on NBC for
barry goldwater
so his speech is so good that barry
goldwater's like let's get you on TV
yeah yeah yeah
but after Goldwater lost two of
Goldwater skies move over to Reagan's
camp and they and some other rich guys
got together and quote became Ronald's
kitchen cabinet okay so they're
basically unofficial advisors rich guys
they're asking him to run for governor
of California so Ronald starts giving
speeches around the state in 1964 ronald
called free speech protests at UC
berkeley acts of quote anarchy with
attempts to
destroy the primary purpose of the
university is this really the first time
where someone is using that kind of let
that way it is so Trumpy in that
language so I mean is this wall no yeah
there were people before then like
father Coughlin father Coughlin and and
his group were very very you know
Jimmy's retired but yeah it's not a very
anak Powell over in England under the
rivers of blood speech there were there
were apocalyptic people that were that
would use that to rile people right and
and but Reagan's just following there's
yeah yeah it worked well it keeps
building McCarthy is like this for sure
so he warned of quote against timeout
Berkeley he warned of quote orgies so
vile I cannot describe it to you but
I'll try my new album Ron talks about a
blood orgy
Georgie non Reagan's new hour they're
[ __ ] monkeys this was around the time
I think he did his last TV movie and it
was a the killers and it featured a
scene where Ron slaps Angie Dickinson
and then John Cassavetes punches out
Ronald raising that was his last just
Cassavetes and he knocks Reagan down
like a punchy monoxide so Ronald is out
there speaking he opposes Civil Rights
Act and the Voting Rights Act
middle-aged white working-class guys
super into oh sure Ronald wins the GOP
primary New York Times quote California
Republicans against all counsels of
common sense insisted upon nominating
actor Ronald Reagan for governor mm-hmm
accredit Governor Pat Brown called
Ronald a right-wing extremist and he ran
a TV ad in which he was in a high school
class he's talking to the students and
then he tells a young black female
student quote I'm running against an
actor do you know who shot Lincoln don't
you oh Jesus Christ
I mean that is
as hey mudslinger each I am NOT a fan of
Ron but goddamn dude Matt yeah oh yeah
he's the extremist yeah by the way I'm
out of my [ __ ] mind
yeah class is this yeah that's amazing
for his part Ronald was on the cover of
Look magazine standing next to a black
lawn jockey statue with large white lips
in front of his ranch a hard choice
between these two yeah yeah Ronald one
on the landslide oh my god the outgoing
first lady gave Nancy a tour of the
governor's mansion and the press tagged
along Nancy said it was a firetrap at an
eyesore nice done on the film's well
while the press is fair walk it to the
ex first lady the ex first lady says
quote we loved living in this house
Nancy quote oh I'm sure you did kinda
awkward she's awful yeah I mean but
exactly I mean you're being filmed awful
people normally know when the cameras on
I guess what I think Nancy secretary
called the Browns to ask them to move
out of the mansion several days early so
she could fix it up okay they didn't
know Nancy told Women's Wear Daily
which by the way I still get it's so
good I get better look monthly still I
love that and look my Bible yeah she
told Women's Wear Daily that she would
be she could be happy anywhere with Ron
Ronald and the kids were with her not
just not his original kids yeah but only
eight-year-old rama's at home patty was
a boarding school Michael and Maureen
were with Jane Nancy also didn't allow
them to be publicly seen with their
father it's very easy to love your
children when you see them at holidays
yeah it yeah you know if I don't if I
don't see my kids at tu b'shvat every
year it's a piece of my heart I the
piece of my heart is gone
you're a good dad I don't get I don't
get your waves to them from the front
lawn the Reagan's lasted
one month in the governor's mansion what
Nancy quote this place is just not safe
it backs up on the American Legion Hall
where I swear there are vile orgies
every night that's where orgies are let
me timeout water canal while I slap you
with my dick like what the hell does she
think goes on an American Legion foxhole
[Laughter]
Jesus I'm gonna bring that back about
the orgies seems like a hot area yeah go
to orgies Alya would not shock anyone no
mommy so she told the press that she
said to Ronnie I can't let my children
live there so friends they don't they're
in boarding school yeah that anyway
right right so friends bought a fancy
house and leased it to the Reagan's and
then Nancy complained quote wouldn't you
think that the state would provide a
residence for the governor and his
family yeah Nance they did yeah they did
so the state paid for the rent what a
new fancy house and began building a new
huge mansion what so relatable yeah
really
salt of the earth yes yeah exactly you
know Nancy supervised the construction
and a lot of people said it was a bad
use of state funds because there was a
recession on now as someone who has
worked construction let me tell you this
is the worst person in the world
the person who while you're painting is
like it doesn't look like it's dry I get
it wet paint you could go to your room I
can just handle this so California is in
serious debt so Ronald makes cuts he
lays off career employees he slashed the
state's university budget and ended free
tuition
he cut 3,700 jobs in mental health and
closed hospitals the year after a study
revealed the num
mentally ill people entering San Mateo's
criminal justice system had doubled I
mean right there yeah that I mean just
such an indicator of where we are today
it is it's just this pulling of that
thread really shows like today that's
why that's and that's when Luke Donald
Trump is like saying like we got to get
the homeless off the streets like yeah
well let's take there was a way to do
that there used to be a check so Ronald
campaigned on a pledge to quote clean up
the mess at Berkeley remember the
protest yeah what year is this though is
this now 6465 oh god what years yeah I
think so yeah
look I don't know it's it's 60 it's late
60s six okay again I'm not defending Ron
Reagan but to that generation what was
happening on campuses must have seemed
like the end of the world oh yeah they
they could not oh yeah fathom what was
going on right and they were these
people were freaking out that generation
[ __ ] their pants yes and Spencer Tracy
they [ __ ] the tub and puke in it - yeah
they spent it you've also got you know
the [ __ ] summer love and like just oh
yeah I mean really that's probably where
a lot of yes coming from so Ronald
called the University a quote haven for
communist sympathizers protesters and
sex deviants orgies sure after riots in
Detroit Newark and Watts the Department
of Defense came up with operation garden
plot I don't like it already already any
time they any [ __ ] time a government
agency gives something a nice name
operation spring sunshine okay you
fertilize the garden board what
hey it was a plan to deploy federal
forces domestically when it looked like
violence might break out now their
version of violence breaking out was
protest by minority peaceful protest
housing or whatever
how dare they Ronald was a big part of
this at the state level at a 1969
operation garden plot meeting Ronald
said the operation was in line with the
quote 6000 year history of man pushing
the jungle back creating a clearing
where man can live in peace and go about
their business business with some
measure of safety
[Music]
that's a dog bullhorn by the way that's
odd right right oh we're not done of
late the jungle has been creeping in
again a little closer to our boundaries
this is [ __ ] yeah that's not coded
yeah no really yeah you'd almost be like
if a president today like tweeted like
the word savages Jewish and people of
color though in it's weird yeah savages
yeah a little weird
anyway I well again but like we said yes
is not we we've evolved I mean my visit
the 65th Lord we're 50 years down the
road we're fine now
now you see Berkeley had a two point
acre plot off campus that they were
gonna build student housing on but then
they ran out of money so the site became
a pile of debris and rusting cars
so then locals came and cleaned it up
and built a public park naming it the
People's Park Ronald did not like this
it was seen as a challenge by leftist on
property rights it's a park like parks
I don't part it parks don't have
political affiliation yeah
they have jungle gyms and also you don't
have property rights of you not using
the frigging price yeah that's right
yeah I'll rubble that's a that's a good
that's capitalist rubble their parents
bring that rubble back get it back level
it up again that'll teach you
I want rusty cars he told school
administrators to act the school and
park organizers began negotiating a deal
when at 4:30 a.m. on May 15 1969 police
arrived with a fencing company an 8 foot
tall fence was put up around the park
then at noon that day students held a
rally on campus and then they marched
peacefully to the park
cops were guarding it
a fire hydrant was open and some police
were soaked then they fired tear gas
then people threw rocks sheriff's
deputies were called in by Ronald and
guards from a local jail who were not
trained as deputies it'll be fine
yeah I don't know why you're making a
weird face yeah there were eight hundred
officers oh my god and then more
protesters arrived Reagan's office told
police to use whatever methods they
wanted that's a great thing to say it
creatives here's my pit and please take
this in the write and record have at it
and please have fun really explore the
space use the protesters body to beat
another protestor up go go crazy
cops moved in swinging their night
sticks and then fired teargas as people
ran away they then began shooting
shotguns some people were on the roof of
a bookstore watching and a sheriff's
deputy shot at the roof james rector was
hit six times Jesus Ronald claimed the
people on the roof were throwing rebar
and that the pavement couldn't be seen
because it was covered in bricks rocks
and the bodies of sheriff's deputies who
had fallen but that is clearly a lie
because there's photographs james rector
died Jesus another student was blinded
reporter saw cops shooting at people who
were running away at least a hundred and
twenty eight people were sent to the
hospital with serious injuries thirty of
them had been shot a doctor at the
hospital quote the indiscriminate use of
shotguns was sheer insanity so crazy
when asked why the police use such force
ronald answered quote it is very naive
to assume that you should send anyone
into that kind of conflict with the
flyswatter conflict i mean that is what
gets so frustrating to the poor right
the creation of the conflict to complain
about the conflict and overreact and
then blame the people who aren't that's
that's a very fascist yes but it is
absolutely the goddamn brown shirts
going to ya Union and communists and
then starting trouble and then when they
fight like see how violently we right
why Yeah right what could we do my god
this is terrible yeah it's putting your
favor in front of some
face until they push it away and then
you liked him he used to code physically
judge it me which I'd have to destroy
yeah yeah
so Ronald declared a state of emergency
and sent in the National Guard on May
20th National Guard helicopters flew
over the Berkeley campus spraying tear
gas Wow wind blew it into a hospital and
elementary schools I mean come on it's
hard to be governor he's like sending in
the National Guard to a problem like the
police were shooting people the National
like this is like a day later so now
it's just people on campus he's just
yeah school just walking to class Ronald
would later concede this may have been a
quote tactical mistake oh yeah you know
that's why I want to bomb the wind on
May 22nd two days later five hundred
people arrested many of them were not
even protesters they were jailed and
beaten
a year later Ronald stuck by his
decision quote if it takes a bloodbath
let's get it over with no more
appeasement Lord appeasement it's very
violent rhetoric saying yeah he was
re-elected in 1970 with 53% of the vote
yeah Wow
after that after all that he Hooper like
that's our guy who's he running he he
killed someone like his orders yeah
killed someone right who was standing on
a roof watching and that's him yeah so
he got 53% of the vote
his priority was welfare reform he spoke
about lady welfare cheats and said his
staff quote discovered thousands of
people who receiving welfare checks at
the same time they were gainfully
employed and one cobble earned more than
$100,000 between them there was
absolutely no proof of any of these
statements Ronald was met Ronald was
known to accept whatever the last person
he spoke to told him
if his staff fight back to have his
superpower not a popular extra I could
repeat whatever [ __ ] I just heard
let's go if his staff would come in to
give both sides of an argument he would
accept the first thing you heard and say
that was the way to get it yeah so the
staff began working everything out
before they would bring it to him right
in 1971 the day after the UN voted to
recognize the People's Republic of China
Ronald called Nixon invented about the
delegates who voted against the u.s.
quote last night I tell you to watch
that thing on television as I did to see
those those monkeys from those African
countries damn them they're still
uncomfortable wearing shoes and Nixon
laughed hard up raw riously there's that
audio of it right it's recent they found
that very recently just uncovered it all
right that's fun there you go just a
couple of presidents chewing the fat you
know what look if it makes you read they
should do that as a Crank Yankers
when watergate broke Ronald said it was
not criminal just illegal as evidence
came out people bailed on Nixon but
Ronald hung in there saying they were
quote not criminals at heart heart is
good I'm the wizard he didn't run for
governor again the mansion they built
was just being finished when he left
office turned it into a park the new
Governor Jerry Brown refused to limit
calling it quote garish expensive Taj
Mahal Brown instead lived in a
two-bedroom apartment mmm
California eventually sold the mansion
in 1984 without a governor ever living
there Wow they just really just refix up
the old mansion the one that you hated
right
Ronald's cabinet wanted him to run for
president and he didn't want to he was
now making good money with a radio job
and writing a column Nancy want him to
run she consulted three astrologers all
said 1976 was not the right
year but she still pushed him to run and
he agreed he went with what is called
the Southern Strategy appealing to
racist their coded language he launched
his campaign with a speech emphasizing
states rights in Philadelphia
Mississippi where three civil rights
workers have been murdered in 1964 again
the most uncoded coda now yeah he spoke
there he spoke of dismantling the Civil
Rights Commission opposing affirmative
action and cutting federal ties to
cities with social programs that were
seen as been a benefit to black people
like subsidized housing this is when he
first invented the woman on welfare in
Chicago who has 18 aims 30 addresses
from episode 2 a welfare queen right
right Jesus all made up he made up a big
thing about this woman and she turns out
ronald sometimes got his knowledge from
letters that people sent him that's not
good no one did you just hold it up to
his head without opening it he was funny
sis boom bah yeah he was super into
letters writing and getting them the
president knew who the postman the
postman Bobby we'd one person wrote and
said there was more oil in Alaska than
Saudi Arabia so Ronald put it in the
speech great there you go perfect oh why
didn't we know more about we could have
sent him the crazy
oh my god such a pleasure
exactly you know there's a secret colony
on the moon ruled by Vincent Price the
best waters in volcanoes another person
wrote about disposing of nuclear waste
by turning it into golf ball-sized
objects and then launching them into the
ocean
perfect Ronald's chem from the manager
convinced him to quote save that one for
later ever run up I think the issue is
that one's too good let's hold on to
that one for a little while let's sit on
that one
whew yeah let's when you make the
running
he Raul was also massively influenced by
right-wing magazines an article in the
ultra conservative magazine Human Events
that Ronald to say on the radio that
Henry Kissinger was behind a secret plan
to give away the Panama Canal which
could lead to Americans having their
mail monitored by Panama's Intelligence
Agency ok wait lots happening there's so
much done back there so somehow and
reconize Ford's Secretary of State I
know and but somehow our mail goes
through the Panama Canal
do you know mail works I went to public
spa
we have Sloane figured that out we take
all of our mail on the East Coast and of
course he's paranoid about where the
what's happening to the mail he's like
moving my fax the Panamanian to put
crazy [ __ ] in there Nancy made sure he
got rest I was campaigning always he had
an afternoon nap
oh and it looked adorable start coming
out oh boy and his schedule had to be
approved by an astrologer oh I don't
think you should have lunch then yeah
not with mercury in retrograde look at
Taurus does he eat ham he needs to stop
look at Taurus so Ford got the
nomination but Ronald shifted voters to
the right he ran again in 1979 but he
almost took the nomination away from
Ford there was a it was a huge mess yeah
yeah I was close
so I'm number four on number 4th 1979
Iranian students Eve sees the US Embassy
in Tehran and took 52 Americans hostage
Reagan became the GOP candidate and
offered the VP slot to George HW Bush
Bush had campaigned in favor of the
Equal Rights Amendment abortion rights
and gun control but he tossed it all
aside and
Brackins platform Wow hey so check it
out everything I believe in is out the
window hey you know who was also very
much for gun control back in the 60s in
California was Ronald Reagan because the
Black Panther is really in trying to
open carry right and then he was oh no
you know we need gun control right
that's right yeah that's how you gonna
dine that out but yeah all right sorry
that's right would there's just there's
so much different I know it's it's just
it's a gallery of Horrors so Bush and
Reagan's campaign slogan let's make
America great again wait was it oh my
god yeah that's if I was so not aware of
I was only 11 let's make America great
again fantastic yeah the country was in
bad shape high inflation high
unemployment and energy crisis in the
hostage situation Ronald ran the exact
same campaign is 76 even Nancy gave anti
busing speeches he wanted slash taxes
and him opposed unemployment insurance
or his he called it quote vacation money
for the lazy old man Potter this is the
only country that shits on vacations you
don't like every other nation in the
world is like what do you need a month
ago for a year you know in America it's
like what you got a day yeah how dare
you not grind 24 come on that's how you
enjoy life here those machines creeping
over so ronald 144 states in December it
was reported Nancy didn't understand why
the Carter's wouldn't move out of the
White House early so she could get
started on redecorating
well to be fair she knows what she's
doing during the transition word came
that Ronald seemed uninterested a
Washington Post headline on December 18
1979 quote Reagan on the sidelines he
often seems remote from transition
longtime aide ed Meese countered that
Ronald quote is really running things
Wow well validating thank you so much no
he's actually smart no no damn he got me
he does stuff oh what a shocker on
January 12th 1981 wrong
inaugurated Carter hadn't slept in 48
hours because his administration was
negotiating for four days straight to
get the hostages out he agreed to lift
some sanctions against Iran if the
hostages were returned as Ronald began
his address the hostages were freedom in
his speech Ronald told a story from the
movie marine Raiders as if it were real
[Laughter]
who can forget when that giant ape
rampage through Manhattan in 1933 we
still recover those brave biplane
fighters brought him down but in the end
it was Beauty killed the Beast
yesterday I'm introducing the kong
amendment why didn't he like yeah why
didn't you confuse like more exciting
movie oh my god King Kong was our
greatest threat back there and we got
rid of him everyone talks about saving
the environment but there are black
lagoons filled with Gillman we want to
steal our female swimmers we have to
stop the spiders from Mars now is the
time for Mothra he also talked about a
soldier who had died in World War one
who was buried in Arlington but the
press looked into it and there was no
soldier buried by that name in Arlington
times confronted the White House who
said Ronald didn't mean to imply the
soldier was buried in Arlington yeah we
couldn't find a private Seymour butts in
Arlington he misspoke someone wrote that
in a letter that was in a letter he got
on inauguration day Ronald visited
Speaker of the House Tip O'Neill O'Neill
showed him a desk that had been
President Grover Cleveland's Ronald
looked at it and said he played Grover
Cleveland in a movie and an eel then
told Ronald he had actually played
Grover Cleveland Alexander the baseball
player not the president oh my god Wow
the recall what that's not good news and
that's white tips spent the next eight
years hammered
I'm a tipping point he took his two-year
chip out toss it in the Potomac it just
started I mean literally as I was doing
the tub the best and all the research
the best quotes and I take him out cuz
there's so many but it's just tip
o'neill going he's a [ __ ] there's a
long pause before you react so instead
of chief of staff Ronald had what was
called the troika Jim Baker ed meese and
Mike Deaver ran it together
three just findt wonderful human being
moral upright men what if we got three
Psychopaths yes
so Deaver got along great with Nancy
they shared interests and he got into
astrology alexander haig was appointed
Secretary of State William Clark who
worked for Reagan and California was
appointed Undersecretary of state at his
hearing he was asked if he was familiar
with the struggles of the British Labour
Party said he was not do you know which
European nations don't want us nuclear
weapons on their soil he didn't know
could he named the prime minister of
South Africa quote I cannot sir Prime
Minister of Zimbabwe nope
on and on comfortably hanging in there
with those punches it nope also noting
our current president drawn a blank not
sure the US had a sixty billion dollar
deficit Ronald announced a federal
hiring freeze halted pending regulations
including airbags and cars and energy
standards for new buildings and he said
he wanted a ten percent income tax
reduction for each year in 81 82 and 83
to make up for that he would cut federal
employee benefits food stamps child
nutrition programs unemployment
insurance welfare benefits and money for
art humanities and sciences 83 federal
programs were gutted it only saved 41
billion and then he gave tax cuts to the
oil industry in savings and loans and
military spending limit by 28 billion
there we go
and we're off yep
this was supply-side economics everyone
called it Reaganomics or trickle-down
economics or as George Bush had called
it in the campaign
voodoo economics because it was absolute
[ __ ] yeah it is literally never
worked
no never call it trickle down
yeah like they've gotten pretty good at
renaming [ __ ] and they don't wrinkle
down mazing and the house was controlled
by Democrats so they push back on the
tax cuts on the day that Ronald's
government declared ketchup would now be
counted as a vegetable in school lunches
so what a great time yeah what that's
like what it's like America's coming out
party
ketchups a [ __ ] vegetable yeah on the
same day it was announced that Nancy
spent over two hundred thousand dollars
on new China Wow
people weren't happy annex aid explained
quote it would be a mistake to say per
se that ketchup was classified as a
vegetable ketchup in combination with
other things is classified as a
vegetable like when asked what those
things were quote french fries are my
god it's a if it's with meat okay
sawdust is a grain Matt James Watt who
was Secretary of the Interior was a bit
religious at a hearing he asked if
natural resources must be preserved for
future generations and he said yes okay
but quote I do not know how many future
generations we can count on before the
Lord returns which by the way that our
current guy Mike Pompeo is saying we
will fight and I ran until the rapture
no yeah that he says that and he said
that multiple times we will fight until
the rapture oh that's comforting so
there you go in December night like that
moment where it's all done I just hope
there's enough oxygen for us to breathe
in that nothing is happening when it's
all said and done we can at least look
at the people who've been calling this
moment
died together in December 1984 nuns were
raped and executed in El Salvador this
was just one of many atrocities
committed by the government back death
squads against leftist but due to the
fight against communism
Ronald Kipp funding the government of El
Salvador one of his top foreign policy
advisors Jean Kirkpatrick said quote
they were not just nuns they were
political activists I mean [ __ ] and they
also it killed a [ __ ] priest right
here maro yeah I mean the fact that you
like that doesn't mean anything they
were murdered yeah yeah that doesn't
mean anything it has no yeah Secretary
of State Alexander Haig told the House
Foreign Affairs Committee that quote
perhaps the vehicle the nuns were riding
in may have tried to run a roadblock or
may have accidentally been perceived to
have been doing so and there may have
been exchange of gunfire when it
exchange
so the whip they're saying the gun that
the nuns were shooting guns with young
he's saying that the nuns might have
been armed they were sexually assaulted
yeah there's exactly so there's like
even if you were to be like okay they
were killed why is there that middle
stuff Jesus yeah in a gun battle can the
lack of soul you have to have I mean
really like I I would never say stop
talking because you want to hear the
darkness and ride people but how is
someone not just like dude just and also
again not that this [ __ ] they're they're
[ __ ] evil people but not only are
they saying this [ __ ] you're saying
they're saying they then went and got
eight hours sleep that's right right
I've lost nights of sleep because I
thought that oh I think I may have lied
to that said the wrong thing or I
offended him exactly all right I promise
something and now I can't deliver it I'm
gonna let someone down and these people
are excusing the rate of nuns and then
just went right to bed like The Three
Stooges with like just like none contrib
least goddamn sociopaths yeah yeah hey
hey Glenn told the US ambassador to send
a cable stating the military's making
progress investigating the murders and
the Ambassador refused reading quote I
will have no part of a cover-up he
soon removed fortunately according to a
CBS poll on 25% of Americans knew El
Salvador was in Central America
Wow ketchup is a vegetable here March
30th 18 1981 as Ronald Reagan left the
DC Hilton he was shot by 26-year old
John Hinckley jr. who was super into
Jodie Foster he left a note in his hotel
room quote Jodie I'm asking you to
please look into your heart and at least
give me the chance with this historical
deed to gain your respect and love she
didn't go for she didn't work no
remember them being married yourself
right yeah a DC police officer a Secret
Service agent and press secretary James
Brady were also shot Brady was shot in
the head a shot glanced off the bullet
proof panel of the car pancaked
and hit the president under the arm then
lodged in his lung just one inch from
his heart there was a real possibility
he would die in the White House went
into turmoil George Bush was on a plane
heading to Texas and he was told to
return Secretary of State Alexander Haig
then declared himself in charge oh wow
well then it was like it's me he goes up
this quote the helm is right here and
that means right in this chair for now
constitutionally until the vice
president gets here but he was wrong was
supposed to like every kid children
schoolhouse rock song about it right so
Haig went into the press room and was
asked who was in charge quote
constitutionally gentlemen you have the
President the Vice President and
Secretary of State in that order and
should the president decide he wants to
transfer the helm to the vice president
he will do so as of now I am in control
here in the White House pending the
return of the vice president and in
close touch with him I mean they came up
I would check with him of course so he
is is he saying he's higher than the
vice president no he's saying right now
I know but he's in the air because he's
in the air okay I wasn't sure if it was
like it's also because he's not here
it's kind of me forever maybe this is
another
but also wasn't John weren't John
Hinckley's parents like either friends
of the bushes or front like no I don't
know you know there was a more of it he
wasn't just some random weirdo right he
was connected to them socially or
something it was some yeah with some
weirdness coming out a cocktail party at
various so uh my son let me just start
with he's crazy he doesn't get women hey
do we have violent video games I was
gonna sorry that's another ten years
yeah so Jodie how did you a job in his
defense candleshoe is a great movie that
was so good
so after this the secretary defense
secretary confronted Haig and Hague said
quote look you better go home and read
your constitution buddy that's the way
it is it's like an old 1940 hey you go
read your Constitution
put your Constitution on your pillow see
if it's in they throw out Moses all over
all kids all around his kids Russia's DC
patty and Ron were allowed to see him
immediately Nancy told Maureen and
Michael he was too weak to see that oh
wow of course you know what he to [ __ ]
play on player yeah don't you ever stop
Nancy he left the hospital in two weeks
and his ratings is approval rating shot
to 68 percent right he asked for major
cuts to Social Security and the Senate
voted against 96 to nothing okay
Ronald then went on TV and a stayer
gonna call their congressman and demand
tax cuts and people did Congress finally
gave in he got 25% tax cuts over three
years there was this was the biggest
reduction in US taxes in the past
seventy years when he signed the time to
go Hinckley good work yeah when he
signed the tax cuts he was in the middle
of a 28 day vacation that his California
ranch his dog walked by and a reporter
asked what the dog's name was Ronald
quote lassie mili mili
Millie's her name
lastly is something wrong with the
president girl what's going on Lassie
the president's mind leaving it what's
going on I mean this is [ __ ] 81 87
yeah there's rose that was the last few
months no no and June Brown was at a
reception for mayor's he walked up to a
black mayor and said quote how are you
mr. mayor I'm glad to meet you how are
things in your city he was not a mayor
he was Samuel Peirce Ronald's only black
cabinet member in 1981 there was a
strange I just pretend you're the mayor
it's so awkward
I'm not your housing secretary over in
flap evil snap Eve is doing good is it
though you guys had some trouble oh god
bless flappy fella I got to come back
there I love the cotton candy pool but
I'm a jet plane fly out of the room now
[Music]
in 1981 there was a strange disease
affecting mostly gay men on July 3rd
1981 the New York Times published an
article about it the media started
calling it gay related immune deficiency
syndrome or grids for short also the gay
plague and the gay cancer the White
House made no mention of it the
professional air traffic controllers
organization Petco was threatening to go
on strike they're one of the few unions
who had backed Ronald in the election
because many were veterans Ronald had
told the union head quote if I am
elected president I will take whatever
steps are necessary to provide our air
traffic controllers with the most modern
equipment available and to adjust staff
levels he did absolutely none of that
and the membership authorized a strike
Ronald said public employees couldn't go
on strike but public employees had
struck in the past and it took 21 weeks
to be trained to be an air traffic
controller so they thought this gave
them power and at Union meetings would
stay say stuff like quote what are they
gonna do fire us all yeah
on August 31st the union of 13,000
members struck Ronald declared them in
violation of the law and gave them 48
hours to return to work
a judge backed him and ordered patco to
pay $100,000 for each hour they were
striking 1,300 went back to work the
rest were fired and banned from federal
employment for life some unit for life
life Reigate sorry clinton reversed it
okay some union officials were arrested
with military controllers Harlan County
USA [ __ ] yeah and I mean literally like
like Matawan coal miners strike [ __ ]
yeah oh my god yeah and okay
with military controllers and
supervisors the FAA operated at seventy
percent of normal the government trained
new controllers patco had some demands
like taking flights to get familiar with
the pilots landing experience and Ronald
used these saying there were unnecessary
perks to get the public on his side the
Ford had been not acceptable to replace
workers with scabs but now that was over
firing workers was legitimized as a
response to labor disputes and this
became a huge blow to labor for ever
yeah I mean really that is kind of like
it we've never really recovered never
that right because it was like the
tipping point where you know it was now
acceptable to do that yeah there were a
lot of leaks to the press from the White
House
Ronald's budget director was quoted in
Atlantic Monthly article saying quote
none of us really understand what's
going on with these numbers and that
supply-side economics was quote a Trojan
horse to bring down the top rate Ronald
the veto to stopgap spending bill and
shut down the federal government for the
first time in history Tip O'Neill said
quote he knows less about the budget
than any president in my lifetime he
came and carry on a conversation about
the bubble it but about the budget it's
an absolute and utter disgrace
glug-glug my face isn't ready yet and
then you would eat nine pizzas
[Applause]
anyway I broke my record for pizza any
questions on that
eight nine pies in what would become a
repeating pattern Ronald at a fundraiser
said a blind man had written him a
letter saying of cutting off his pension
would help the country he was for it
Ronald said the letter was written in
Braille but he gave absolutely no proof
of this letter he would talk about
letters like this for the rest of his
presidency and never give any proof yeah
is there Braille paper like that I think
you can write a baby Braille you do it
in a circle looks like a bore you do it
with a little punch thing right okay so
many leaps I'm a blind man with no hands
who was allergic to paper wrote me a
letter saying so I wrote him back by
punching a pen into it I hope it made
sense looked like his might have been is
now there was also too much cheese
there's not the first president I
remember I remember those dark years
yeah we need a hero
my uncle better the cheddar war in the
cheddar surplus a huge wheel of edom
crushed him we need macaroni now more
than ever during the 70's dairy prices
had shot up and the government
intervened and prices plummeted
so carter subsidized the dairy industry
which led to a surplus in dairy and
cheese okay eventually there were 500
million pounds of cheese stored in
hundreds of warehouses in 35 states okay
and Ronald had no idea what to do with
this issue cheese crisis the only thing
that's keeping me up I can't sleep
cheese gate so it's processed American
cheese designed to last a long time
this became public when the agricultural
secretary came to a White House event
with a five-pound
lack of green molding cheese he showed
it to the press and said quote it's
moldy it's deteriorating we can't find a
market for it we can't sell it we're
looking to try to give it away somehow
the public became very upset because
Ronald ran on cutting welfare but he was
hoarding cheese I mean we like what
bothers us and like what our dummy yeah
like we don't know anything we'll be off
Congress people for tax cuts that will
our lives worse well we're kicking
mental patients out of hospitals to die
on the street everybody should want to
see pictures on a cheese house we're not
idiots
storm the cheese open these doors hi
boys
start munching so don't you chase
[ __ ] so wrong well on TV and
gave a speech about cheese quote somber
night in the White House well at a time
when American families are under
increasing financial pressure their
government cannot sit by and watch
millions of pounds of food turn to waste
the temporary emergency food assistant
program was created and it handed out
blocks of cheese to elderly low-income
people and aid organizations people
lined up to get their cheese at the end
of 1981 Ronald Reagan's approval rating
was it 49 percent even after the cheese
giveaway I mean we have to do oh and I
like the way that it's like I mean it's
a problem it's like I'll just give away
all the cheese to the old people yeah
this is not what's happening in America
right now well we found a home yeah
that's the end of our first half oh my
god what if what a wonderful place today
that's yeah it would be amazing if it
ended there but guys hang on I think
there's a second part the cool thing is
the sing apart is where it gets really
crazy
well then I with that I'm gonna use the
restroom and get a beverage all right
Wow solid